all right roberto this show has been a
fan favorite it still is but there is
some speculation that it's coming to an
end so what are you set of fans you're
wondering i i have not heard that um uh
you know i think i think the only thing
we can all acknowledge is that you know
there's there's more road behind us than
ahead of us
um but we're still in the thick of
season six we got renewed for season
seven
there's a lot of story left to tell you
know when we when we first pitched
riverdale we had a very clear
destination
in in mind and we are not there yet
so i'm i'm psyched to keep telling these
stories but i that's all i know i hear
there's a musical
that we can expect yes
um this year we're doing you know we're
continuing our tradition of reviving a
cult musical this year we're reviving uh
a cult musical based on the movie
american psycho
uh which duncan sheik wrote
the songs for
which was a broadway flop
but it fits in with our story because
we're telling a big serial killer story
and there is going to be a serial killer
convention in riverdale so as part of
that convention we're putting on uh
american psycho the musical that sounds
amazing it is amazing we've just been
filming it this week wow and i hear
karen and shivka is coming back
i have heard those rumors as well i
believe she will be coming back for a
visit um and we're really really excited
we loved having her before and we're
very very excited that she's coming
we back return to the old ways
it's just how things roll on riverbelt
so looking back over the pat over the
last five years a lot has happened but
do you have a favorite moment or scene
or episode that you can recall you know
i always i mean i i think the pilot is
is is just a beautiful episode of of
television and when i think back to
other episodes
i'm i'm very
i get very emotional whenever i think of
the episode the tribute episode we did
for luke perry
um
that was such a
a raw
emotional
time for everyone
and we really wanted to honor the
character of fred andrews but really we
wanted to honor
luke perry
um so i'm very very proud of that but
but i but i always think of those two
episodes as uh amongst my favorites as a
creator what has this show what has it
taught you about you
what has been the best experience for
you yeah i mean i it's funny this show
has gone so far beyond my expectations
you know we we fought so hard to get it
made sold
uh you know it was in development for
years we started
trying to do it as a movie
um so it kind of taught me a little bit
about uh that that taught me a little
bit about perseverance and then i think
you know the other thing is it's sort of
it's a humbling thing to work on a show
for so long for on work on a show that
means so much to people
and i'm i'm just so grateful to all of
the people the cast the writers the crew
that is incredible up in vancouver who
have all worked so hard and given so
much to this show it's it's kind of a
humbling thing so i think i think that's
what i'm holding on to more than
anything that kind of the deeper we get
we get involved in this